herzlich willkommen zur heute schon
neuerdings mit 2 g + + publikum also
geimpft genesen frisch getestet und mit
maske mir wurde erzählt manche hätten
sogar geduscht meine damen und herren
so zu corona kommen wir gleich hilft ja
nix jetzt erstmal zum reinkommen was
schönes fürs gemüt die kleine ampel ist
da
ja ein kind der liebe
hervorgegangen aus einer ganz modernen
dreier patchwork familie am mittwoch sie
werden es sicher live geguckt haben
haben sie den koalitionsvertrag
vorgestellt in berlin unter der
poetischen überschrift mehr fortschritt
wagen ja das geht richtig in die tiefe
kurz im gespräch waren auch zukunft ist
das was noch kommt und
friede freude dinkel kuchen ist aber
nicht geboten
grüne mit spd und fdp das ist nämlich
viel mehr als nur das nächste
zweckbündnis da sind gefühle im spiel
das sind im grunde so was wie wie die
avengers der herzen
[Musik]
wir bilden jetzt eine regierung das
finden sich neue freunde die
spd die grünen und die fdp
und alle fünf freunde das sind wir olaf
chris & drop saskia und an alle hier
gehen
meint absoluten lieblings band der reihe
fünf freunde haben große pläne aber
keine ahnung wo das geld herkommen
sollten
richtig spannend die ampel verspricht
nämlich nicht weniger als die
transformation deutschlands die
finanzierung des ganzen bleibt
allerdings weiter nebulös und das ist
mutig wenn man allein an die korona
schulden denkt ja ist ja so bei
andererseits
investitionen müssen ja sein es muss
trotzdem investiert werden und wenn sich
dafür völlig unterschiedliche politische
lager zusammenraufen das sei umso besser
hauptsache sie können rechnen was aber
eine möglichkeit gibt auch mal den
standpunkt zu wechseln und zu verstehen
dass wenn christian lindner eine 6 auf
der seite sieht und welche einen neuen
sehen dass wir vielleicht beide recht
haben können
gut dass die nicht finanzministerin
geworden ist
wahrscheinlich hat sie früher ihr
zeugnis umgedreht und gesagt ja ich habe
mir neuen in mathe aber
kommt kommt einkommen ich sag mal für
außenministerin reicht sehr
wahrscheinlich das ist ja jetzt das ja
das kann man schaffen andere
ministerposten
andere posten im kabinett scholz sind
derweil noch unbesetzt wissen sie es ist
zb denkt bauen das kann ich gar nicht
fassen dass karl lauterbach am ende
nicht gesundheitsminister wird ja ja ja
gut er hätte dann mehr zeit für die
familie also für markus lanz aber
ich habe es weniger trotzdem das schwere
fehlentscheidung oder einer der wenigen
die in der korona krise ehrlich waren zu
uns bürgern karl magento und lauterbach
sehen wir das positive vielleicht kriegt
er den job ja doch und falls nicht wird
mit karl sich ganz seinem lieblingshobby
sie wissen schon verzweifelt im
bundestag und natürlich richtig
verzweifelt
[Applaus]
japan aber hat vergessen da vor allem
mal die ämter manches was da auf diesen
178 seiten koalitionsvertrag steht das
ist gar nicht so schlecht bei näherer
betrachtung da wurde ja für jeden
koalitionspartner was feines reingepackt
vom nicola von seinem knecht christian
natürlich für die grünen ein
kohleausstieg idealerweise schon 2030
also wenn sich ergibt für die fdp keine
steuererhöhung und kein tempolimit und
für die spd steigt der mindestlohn auf
12 euro oder weniger nüchtern formuliert
mindestlohn ii steigern
und das war vor den legalisierung von
cannabis
so was ist noch drin im ampel sack
kindergrundsicherung zum beispiel finde
ich sehr gut eeg-umlage fällt endlich
weg und jedes jahr 400.000 neue wohnung
ist der plan auf der minusseite leider
gar keine steuerreform keine echte
rentenreform und viele klimaschädliche
subventionen bleiben auch aber reden wir
mal über den chef über unseren kommenden
kanzler der sagt wehrführung bestellt
der kriegt sie auch ja jetzt ist nämlich
mal schluss mit dem ewigen urlaub schulz
hat kein charisma genörgel so langweilig
wer den scholz auch nur einmal hinter
den kulissen erlebt hat der vergisst ihn
nie wieder deswegen auch den von
künftigen bundeskanzler olaf schmidt
angekündigt
expertenrat so nämlich olaf schmidt
allerbestes kanzler material was der
damals in der hamburger sturmflut
geleistet hat oder war dass der g20
gipfel ist ja auch egal ja es sprach
volker wissing unser neuer minister für
verkehr und digitales sozusagen
germany's next an die scheuer ja jetzt
geht's voran mit der digitalisierung
freunde ein fdp mann ist bald für ein
digitales zuständig wissen sie was das
heißt es bei uns schon mal bescheid dass
er gleich internet angucken
[Gelächter]
dass sie das noch erleben darf
oma hängt jetzt nur noch von youporn
die ampel verspricht ich zitiere
flächendeckende versorgung mit glasfaser
direkt ins haus dabei hat zitat der
eigenwirtschaftliche ausbau vorrang mit
anderen worten das klappt nie
was man aber meine ich ernst
ausdrücklich mal loben muss diese ampel
verhandlungen die waren derartig diskret
dass nicht mal die lobbyisten was
mitgekriegt haben ja ja es kein scherz
normalerweise geben diese lobby lurche
ja alles um noch einfluss zu nehmen auf
so einen koalitionsvertrag das ging
diesmal nicht besonders hart ist das für
die lobbyisten der großen
wirtschaftsverbände mit ihren
exzellenten unions kontakten die ihnen
bei dieser regierung gar nichts mehr
nützen wenn sie also in berlin gut
gekleidete aber verwahrloste anzugträger
sehen die pfandflaschen sammeln oder
aggressive betteln das sind alles
lobbyisten sie sind verzweifelt weil sie
nicht reingekommen sind bei den opel
verhandlungen dabei haben sie sich mit
allen tricks versucht manche haben sich
sogar als annalena baerbock verkleidet
was erlauben sie sich ich bin die
außenministerin das muss man diesen
lobbyisten lassen die haben nichts
unversucht gelassen nichts
neues gesetz für auto abgaswerte wenn
sie dann an blick drauf werfen wollen
und gutes geschäft noch
ja toni hofreiter hätte man übrigens gar
nicht belästigen müssen der hat kein
ministeramt abgekriegt der start der
ampel reden wir darüber mit unserem
heute schief politiker an all ist mit
olaf schubert oder schön dass du da bist
ja wenn alles klappt wird olaf scholz
sein namensvetter übernächste woche
vereidigt was für ein kanzler wird das
ich fürchte ein bundeskanzler
ja wobei man jetzt nicht ihn alleine da
irgendwie an den pranger stellen soll es
war glaube ich allgemein soll bis ein
tenor bei der wahl dass die
spitzenkandidaten aller parteien jetzt
nicht so ganz spitze waren man hatte
schon die befürchtung wenn das so
weitergeht ist es irgendwann keine
bundestagswahl sondern ihr senat schrott
wichteln aber
das amt ist natürlich wichtig und ich
denke die lücke die frau merkel
hinterlässt die muss man wirklich erst
mal hinten und
olaf scholz hat aber glaube ich wirklich
das potenzial diese lücke zu
vergrößern denn
seine schärfste waffe ist ja wirklich
sage ich mal
ja wie soll man da sagen also seine
seine fehlende ausstrahlung er hat davon
davon macht er gnadenlos gebrauch es ist
ja wirklich so dass man ihm nichts
zutraut gar nichts also nicht mal was
schlecht ist
also er hat so wenig emotionen und
deshalb würde glaube ich eine gute
kanzlerin denn
hitler vergleicht verbieten sich somit
von vornherein ja das ja auch schon ein
pluspunkt im ausland was aber das
schlimmste ist und ich glaube der
tragweite sind sich die meisten menschen
gar nicht bewusst also bei google
android google setzt olaf scholz über
olaf schubert und dass
das macht mich wahnsinnig wirklich
da müssen wir ran die ampel hat große
und teure pläne und will ich zitiere in
nie dagewesenem umfang zusätzliche
mittel einsetzen um das 1,5 grad ziel zu
erreichen wo diese mittel herkommen ist
noch nicht so richtig geklärt wo soll da
schaut daher kommen
wirklich nicht mein problem
ich würde das klären die jede
vernünftige regierung man macht schulden
und
diese schulden stellen wir dann der
kommenden generation zur verfügung
kostenlos körper sie als
startkapital ich meine die jugend will
ja unbedingt das klima retten
dann sollte man ihn auch eine chance
geben das selber zu bezahlen ja das
gehört zum erwachsenwerden dazu dass man
verantwortung übernimmt und im gegenzug
bekommen sie auch viel zurück freiheit
sag ich mal also führerschein mit 16 ja
legal ist cannabis kein tempolimit
wahlrecht mit 16 also das freut mich für
meine kinder zu hause interessen die
können jetzt also im auto mit 280
zugekauft direkt an die wahlurne fahren
und dort afd wählen also mehr freiheit
geht nicht
ja
ich finde ja über viele details dieses
ampel vertrags wird zu wenig berichtet
da stehen ein paar spannende sachen drin
zum beispiel wusstest du dass mann und
frau können zum beispiel endlich beide
denselben doppelnamen tragen wusste ich
gar nicht vor durfte nur einer oder eine
doppeln und geringverdienern werden die
kosten der verhütung erstattet das kann
man alles nur unterstützen oder
unbedingt absolut also gerade das mit
den doppelnamen finde ich ist eine sehr
wichtige eine progressive regelung also
ein wichtiger punkt in richtung
gleichstellung dass beide ehepartner
karl-heinz heißen dürfen
und ich sag mal denn dass man sozial
schwachen die verhütung bezahlt das ist
ja im interesse aller das will ja
niemand da sich die unterschichten heine
ist jetzt noch weiter und pflanzen aber
es ist natürlich trotzdem ungerecht das
muss man ganz klar sagen ja sozial
schwache bekommen kondome umsonst ich
darf mein modell besuch nicht mehr von
der steuer absetzen
was ich meine das ist jetzt nicht die
masse so aber es läppert sich das sind
dann auch 1000 euro in der woche und ich
finde da muss man wirklich noch mal ran
soziale schieflage olaf schubert meine
damen und herren
[Applaus]
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten einfach anklicken
macht's gut
los
los du scheiße fährt haye